engineering here's a signal school hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to three scary good I've
got some good ones lined up for you here
so let's get right into it
welcome to my Gucci chapter holy [ __ ]
hello how you doing
it was getting late most of the kids
were on their way home and fortunately
for them a mysterious power outage it
struck mcubed me something wasn't right
who's too quiet going outside to
investigate wasn't an option for me all
the doors and windows displayed an empty
void that was once the outside world
yeah it's that's a problem my thoughts
were immediately interrupted by the
tunes of a piano that I do not own I
knew that I was not alone upon further
investigation in curiosity I noticed
that some of my most prized possessions
had begun giving off a distinct glow as
I moved closer I felt the warmth of my
true home
perhaps if I collected them and held
them close to my heart I might live to
see another day the laptop the book the
brushes ah yes my prized possessions the
brushes oh my who's playing the piano
who's doing that okay is that the book
did I get the book I think I got the
book Oh blood
Oh upside down oh okay wait hang on a
second oh hello
nothing whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
hey buddy how you should I know I
shouldn't be looking at you
I probably shouldn't anyway I don't know
what I'm collecting I don't know what to
do about you who's gonna try to run by
okay all right we're fine apparently
back we're not fine we're less than fine
ah no no oh oh oh what the [ __ ]
okay all right I don't know what's
happening I don't know this button is oh
hey how you doing how you doing how are
you doing hey how you doing my laptop
uh-oh
I don't know what's going on please
leave me alone
Oh Boyd okay Oh d'Or oh I don't know
where I think I'm at the dead end I
think I'm dead ended I think I'm dead
ended oh I think I'm dead end just the
piano is getting wonky
oh [ __ ] okay mm hello hi
there's no hey how you doing okay that
piano is not getting so happy oh you're
really garden that note pretty close to
the chest ancient
wait oh my god my soul has been consumed
excuse you I don't know woof woof okay
um I don't know what makes him go
what gets him go what gets him going
what doesn't looking at I'm getting
going I don't know if looking at him
gets him going no no I get some going
[ __ ] oh my god okay all right that's
how you're gonna dick with me okay try
that again
the Burke where's the lap etapa
hey so I gotta go this way I gotta go in
here you're a section ranger the book
okay the this whatever this was oh okay
it doesn't help that you just phase
through a wall what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna lure him lure him away hey buddy
what makes you go what makes you go what
make it what making you go
oh you're going oh you're going all
right oh yeah my Gooch
come on mcgoon come on magoons oh come
on mcgoun chief look it's like when you
look at him you charge up his looky-loo
and then three two one look away and he
comes a little bit he doesn't nothing
weird about that my statement is totally
innocent because it meant to be innocent
mr. mcgoon mr. mcgoon mr. Magoo's
you stay right there mr. mcgoon I don't
know what's changing Oh Oh mr. mcgoon
okay mr. mcgoon mr. Magoo mr. mcgoon mr.
mcgoon all right mr. mcgoon see you need
to back the hell up right now
all right mr. mcgoon shoo come through
here wherever you're gonna come through
if you're gonna slip through the wall or
something now is the time to do it
so go for it show me up show me what
you've got
okay that nope not like that not like
that not like that mr. mcgoon okay
you're gonna go far over here mr. McGurn
hi mister magoons can you knock it
through the door I'm mr. mcgoon oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay
all right mr. mcgoon all right come at
me mr. Magoo Sh mr. a douche more like
it there we go live to fight another day
live to fight another day live to fight
another day who could get this whatever
this is going here trying to get this
door and no work
okay go out it's a void and here nothing
over here nothing nothing can't go that
way okay all right mr. Magoo Sh
come here come in unity I got word I got
a word with you I need a word with you
Oh too much word okay all right mr.
Magoo should stay a respectable distance
away from me stairs a block two can't go
up there well that's just fantastic
you got that whatever that did the
song's getting kind of discordant
discourage I'm going in here again but I
don't know why I need brushes what why
why why why why why uh everything looks
weirdly normal I don't know why this is
going great guys it's going great
he's going wonderfully okay all right
three two one fine brushes
three two one brush three two one brush
where it's brush okay I got the brew hey
whoa hey listen now okay out here
out the door with more out the door with
more I'm not out the door I'm not out
the door with more I'm no mr. McGurn
shhhhhh mr. mcgoon mr. mcgoon ch what is
that I don't know Oh
so why what the [ __ ] now what the
[ __ ] so consumed ate a dick I just got
all the files so consumed dick consumed
more like II put the [ __ ] I gotta go
back in I gotta go back in now donut
okay fine then yeah I'm not gonna go for
the files this time because apparently
that just game over to me come on mr.
mcgoon Shh yeah it's just you me now mr.
mcgoon what are you gonna do about it
miss Irma douche mr. mcgunn I don't get
it
oh my health must have gone down oh I
have a health bar that must have been
what it was so if I'm near him caused me
to drop health well that's weird what
the hell
oh so when I'm not look weight but when
I'm looking at him it it also wait then
what does it and what causes my health
to drop I don't even know maybe as long
as he's in like line of sight that's
when problems happen probably okay I
just got to keep him out of sight out of
sight out of mind out of sight out of
mind okay he's coming out of sight out
of mind oh so I don't mind I'm saying
yeah it must be that must be just line
of sight oh god how am I supposed to be
able to survive then find a known that
was the mechanic from the beginning I
would have I wouldn't have spent so much
time basking in his glory the glory of
the goonch where I am you oh [ __ ] there
we go oh [ __ ] me gunch
vegans vegans oh [ __ ] he's right there
oh ye oh that counts I'll suck suck at
it well how am I supposed to be able to
get health back because this is draining
me no wonder I died last time just drain
me of all my health it's probably pretty
close a knee oh [ __ ] yo ho yo homie no
okay no no no no no no no no oh my god
I'm almost dead how did I do it last
time
all right last as long as I did oh [ __ ]
there we go oh [ __ ] no no no no no no no
not this time not this time leave me
with my health leave me give me my
health that's all I need give me my
health that's all I want okay brush
where were the brushes the brushes were
over here you got the brushes oh [ __ ]
okay no don't look at me don't look at
me don't look at me don't look don't
even look don't even try me don't even
try me bro oh [ __ ] that's not gonna work
okay don't try me bro oh oh [ __ ] okay oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] no no no no not my health
not my health not my health cut it off
now come on come the [ __ ] on it's
impossible wait wait
easy God my health is just completely
gone now my health is just gone it's
just gone it's just gone it's like I
might as well not have had it might as
well not have tried [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you are screw this screw this
mmm man it was good it was good but it
had the fatal flaw being very annoying
okay so this one's called dead signal
whoa oh my this is a retro-style [ __ ]
game again but this one set in space
whoo hull breach detected alert state in
effect restart engineer report to bridge
I am floating zero gravity oh this is
cool oh this is neato burrito I love
this one already no I'll do a lot of
things sending me in in an unfamiliar
environment just floating around in the
darkness is not one of those things Oh
Jake the guns not fully repaired only
the pusle repulsor is active come by
later Oh Oh boom oh I've got the
repulsor ah good I've gotten to match my
face perfectly as repulsive as I am all
right any baddies want to be repulsed
oh this is this is crazy I'm so down for
this I've plates what is that is that
bad okay is that okay what is that what
am I looking at what am I looking at
what is that what is that what is any of
this what are you what are you why are
you what are you okay all right
Frick all right okay I've played so few
horror based space space horror games
for space-based horror games I've played
even fewer that are like free floating
no gravity last what I can remember is
actually dead space in just the zero-g
segments that's all I remember nothing
to report except the weird scratching
from the wall someone better fix that
rat problem yeah yeah that's that's
definitely what that was what the [ __ ]
was that what was that what was that I
don't want to know what that was I'm not
okay with what that was
engineering here's a signal school oh
it's a heat ski oh don't come floating
out at me like that that's so creepy
this game is so creepy
not about this no no no no you try try
try try try that's right you better run
you better run oh yeah you better go
where'd you go baby
where'd you go where'd you go yeah
where'd you go yeah where'd you go
you're not so tough now even though I
probably didn't kill you or hurt you in
any way shape or form I feel strong when
I right-click it brings up this blue
overlay that that's the heat thing case
you're all confused why I go blind for a
few seconds all right
[Music]
I don't see anything good would you buy
me just some case I've never felt like
this kind of kind of tension before I
think it's been so long it's I think is
what it is it's the unfamiliarity of it
where's like if I'm playing a normal
horror game and it's just like walking
around in a 3d environment and you know
I'm walking everywhere like it wouldn't
be nearly as bad but because I'm
floating like this it's so weird
and it's unnatural and it doesn't feel
right and I'm not used to it and it
feels not I know it's somehow another
level of terrifying what is that the
kickstart engine apply percussive force
to heated areas a good whack should
teach it what for ah the good old what
is it the the prayer of percussive
maintenance it's like something in for
hammer 40k oh [ __ ] whoa I got an upgrade
[Music]
where are you just go away
yeah I got I got to do these in quick
succession but these things keep getting
in my way so I can't get to it in time
god damn god damn it just let me get to
it god damn [ __ ] hell okay all right
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] stop stop okay
does that do it did I get it
Oh get out of here that's a lot of parts
oh that sounds good or bad that sounds
bad whoa whoa ah okay we got it online
all right okay whoo-hoo jobs done
everybody let's go home let's go Oh
door opening okay right no no give me a
boost give me a boost Pro tactics here
Wow
come out of the woodwork idea oh here
comes another one here comes another one
or that is the doorway come on come on
come on yeah here we go here we go here
we go here we go here we go here we go
come on come on come at me come at me
come at me come at me come at me come on
come at me come a me call me bro call
Matt me oh that's that's a human body
oh [ __ ] though that was probably not the
best idea
oh this marks the end of the sequence
returning you to the Triton oh no I
didn't I didn't know oh no I didn't know
I didn't know
oh I gotta live with that now that was
great but god damn you
god damn you training me to be like that
for and then shooting up friend of my
[ __ ] you oh that's great I love that one
all right this one's called true
nightmares oh boy hello
Oh
I don't know
- Oriole
you
I can't understand you whatever you're
trying to say I don't get watching you
you have to go back to sleep okay
right okay yeah just record your
thoughts like that that's good I guess
that's good
wardog oh hi um don't mind me I'm sorry
whoa oh I can't move I
oh okay Oh
[Music]
okay why do I get flashbacks from
presentable liberty I'm getting very
presented turn the lights back on
oh hey whoa whoa hey whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
pick the sheets off you Klu Klux Klan
get out of here
yeah oh it's open okay that's good I was
I was thinking that it was open I I felt
free what is with these lines weird
lines okay all right
oh this looks this looks good I
definitely like that okay no oh no no no
no no no no no no no all right you want
to fight I'll [ __ ] fight your brother
come on come into my fists go get fisted
dismissed it okay all right then I he
got fisted and I think I'm the way I'm
the victor for that oh wow let me hop in
my car let me put it in Drive and let's
get the [ __ ] out of here
all right let's go go go go and away we
go
I'm not controlling this by the way well
glad that nightmare is over what a true
nightmare that was let's get out of here
and get on the open road let's do this
real slow like I'd like to drive
economically I don't want to waste any
gas you know how it is you know how it
is we all know how it is I know how it
is you know how it is they know how it
is the ghosts know how did what is that
how is that
sound I think it is
hi
whoa oh okay well that's clearly
insurance fraud Oh what the hell whoa
what
huh there's something in the grass over
there Oh got mad hops okay apparently
not oh-oh-oh
this is how this always goes you just
start getting into a game it's got some
interesting concepts no substance to it
no ending no core gameplay it's got just
interesting concepts and then boom it's
done well that's pretty good nonetheless
I would like to see more than I didn't
know where it was going exactly but I
liked the direction that it was going in
if you know what I mean so anyway that
is three scary games if you want to see
more scary games I've got so many scary
games linked down in the description
below I've got a playlist with hundreds
and hundreds of scary games look for it
right down in the description or go to
my channel look at the playlist tabs
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]